خلينا نفترض على افتراض
تجديد عشره الاف دولار في الشهر حلو هذا
الراتب عالي بلا شك اكيد لكن اذا قلنا ان
على الاقل وسط زملائك في العمل هل ستشعرين
بالسعاده يعني
المفروض
اقول حال
اعلى او انت كشخص ضمن اعلى الاشخاص او
اعلى واحد في المئه من اصحاب الدخل في
بلادك لكن على الاغلب انت ستقارن نفسك
بدائرتك المحيطه بك فقط وبالتالي قد تشعر
بعدم الرضا اذا وجدت انك لا تجني مثل
المقربين هو نقاش دائر بين الاكاديميين
وباحثي علم السلوك كاجراء عليها الباحثون
اكثر من دراسه والنتيجه واحده معظمنا غير
راض عن راتبه حتى اصحاب الاجور الكبيره
تبقى يزيد فتزيد حجم مصروفاتك ساعيا وراء
معيشه اكثر رفاهيه على كل حال حديثنا
اليوم ليس عن زياده الرواتب اتمنى يعني
ولكن حول طريقه تقسيم هذا الراتب واداره
الراتب الشهري بالشكل الامثل ليكون كافي
على الاقل يمشينا لتاريخ 29 اللي هم عاش
موعد معاش الراتب
الشهر بشهره مش المفروض يكون هيك قديمه مش
طريقه للحياه يعني اذا نرحب بضيفنا في
الاستوديو احمد سند المهندس هو صنع
المحتوى الاقتصادي يا صباح الخير صباح
الخير صباح الخير تموا الراتب معاش لانه
ما عاش صحيح صحيح
25/2018 بالشهر خالص الراتب كيف نقسم هذا
الراتب حتى لو كان مبلغا كبيرا هو الحقيقه
زي ما قلنا الفتره اللي فاتت دي خصوصا مع
التضخم وزيره الاسعار لكلنا شايفينها كل
حد بيحس ان في خلال شهر او اقل من شهر
الراتب بتاعه بينخفض فلو فضلنا بالشكل ده
تقريبا الراتب بتاعه هينعدم بعد فتره
وخصوصا في دول عربيه او في حتى في امريكا
او في اوروبا فالحل بدايه ان احنا نعكس
العمليه ان احنا عاده بنعيش ان احنا بنصرف
الفلوس وما يتبقى منها ممكن نخليه سيفينز
او ان احنا نحوشه لو عكسنا المفهوم بتاعنا
ان احنا اول ما يبقى الراتب يدخل لنا ان
احنا نحدد بالضبط ايه المبلغ اللي احنا
هنستقطعه شهريا قبل ما نشوف اي مصروفات ان
هو ده الحد الادنى اللي احنا هنحطه على
جنب مبلغ كل شهر نستقطعه من الراتب بتاعنا
ونحطه على جنب راتبنا عشره الاف دولار
نستقطع
بتختلف على حسب كل فئه على حسب كل دخل
شهري وعلى حسب اللي انت تقدر تستقطعه
ولنفترض ان انت تستقطع 10% من دخلك الشهري
دلوقتي وتحطه على جنب وتبدا بعدها تحسب
مصروفاتك هتلاقي اكيد خصوصا الناس اللي
كانت بتستند في كل مرتبها ان في حاجات
مضطر ان هو يستغنى عنها وفي الغالب
الحاجات دي ممكن ما تكونش اساسيه يعني انت
مثلا من المدخنين ممكن يقدر يقلل من
استهلاكه للتدخين مع ان اسعارها بتزيد
دلوقتي وبتاكل اكتر من اللازم من راتب
الشهري ممكن يلاقي بعض المصروفات اللي كان
بيعملها ما كانتش اساسيه او ضروريه هتيجي
على حساب العشره في الميه دي فمجرد ان انت
شهر في التالي بدات تجمع العشر في الميه
هتعمل بعدها حاجه اسمها ايميرجنسي فاند
كلنا شوفنا بعد الكورونا في ناس فجاه
اتفاجات
بالضبط كده حساب للطوارئ ان لا قدر الله
حد تعب محتاج علاج حد فقد وظيفته فجاه
بقرار من الشركه يعمله تسريح للعماله يبقى
معاه مبلغ يكفي ان هو يقدر يعيش لمده شهور
على الاقل فبعد ما عمل او حساب الطوارئ
الست شهور ده يعني اللي هو حط 10% يبتدي
يحسب بيصرف كم في الشهر هيقعد كم شهر يعمل
يحط معه يبقى هو ده مبلغ بتاعه بعد ما
اكتمل المبلغ ده يبدا يفكر في مفهوم
الاستثمار لان مفهوم الاستثمار دلوقتي بدا
يزداد شعبيه وبدات الناس تفكر فيه اكتر بس
في بعض الاحيان الناس بتعمله بشكل غير
محسوب ممكن يدخل بكل الفلوس اللي معاه
بدون علم بدون خبره بدون اي حاجه ويخسر كل
المبلغ اللي هو دخله فبدايه عملت او
الحساب اللي انت بتحطه الطوارئ بعدها
هنفكر في الاستثمار الاستثمار بيختلف طبعا
على حسب مرحلتك العمريه وحسب هدفك من
الاستثمار ده طب احنا لسه ما اكلناش ما
شربناش ما دفعناش مصروف اجار البيت كل قبل
كل هذا الاساسيات كذا كذا بتخرج من السنه
اللي بتاعك او من مرتبك بناء على الثوابت
يعني انت ساكن في مكان معين عارف الايجار
الشهري بتاعك بتدفعه قد ايه بتبتدي تحدد
بتسكن بكم في الميه من دخلك بالتعليم وهو
جزء مهم جدا وي الاهم لتعليم الاولاد او
تعليم بعملها في نفسك وتطوير نفسك تعمل له
نسبه شهريه او نسبه ثانويه على حسب انت
بتخطط له ازاي وترفيه لان مهم جدا ان انت
تهتم بجانب الترفيه ما يبقاش ان انت كل
حاجه بس بتصرفها في الاساسيات اكيد حتى لو
نسبه ضئيله كل شهر وان انت تطور في نفسك
دي نقطه مهمه جدا لان هي اللي هتكون سبب
اصلا ان دخلك يزداد يعني هي زي البيضه ولا
فرخه ان احنا هنزود الدخل بتاعي ازاي وانا
مش بزود المهاراتي ومش بطورها لو انت ما
طورتش من مهاراتك هتفضل زي ما انت ولو ما
اتغيرتش هتتغير يعني لو لو ما غيرتش نفسك
انت هتتغير من شغلانتك وهيجيبوا حد غيرك
على طول فدي نقطه مهمه جدا ان انت ازاي
تحدد بعد ما عملت بتاعتك او المبلغ اللي
انت هتعمله للحساب الطوارئ تحدد بعد كده
المصروفات الاساسيه لتعليم وغيره وبعدها
تبدا تفكر فيه مفهوم الاستثمار لان انت
عمرك ما هتبقى غني زي ما بنقول الا ان انت
تنمي فلوسك تنمي فلوسك عن طريق او مبدا
التراكم الارباح وتراكم الفلوس على بعضها
طيب عشره بالميه هذا
حول الحساب حساب الطوارئ بعد ما نشيل كل
المصروفات الاساسيه اللي احنا مضطرين قديش
المفروض نصرف على مثلا جزء من راتبنا يروح
لاجار البيت قديش المفروض برضه نسبه
للاكل والشرب وبالتالي قديش مفروض يتبقى
معنا لحتى نسبه الاستثمار يكون من هذا
الراتب ب 70 الف سنويا وتقدر تسكن ب 40
صحيح دي نقطه مهمه جدا
اهم حاجه ان ما حدش عايش نفسه في مستوى ما
يقدرش يستطيع ويقدر يكمل به لانه هو لو
دخل نفسه في مستوى ما يقدرش ان هو يصرف
بعد كده على كماليات ورفائيات اللي هو
عايش نفسه فيها فهي هتبقى شكرا جزيلا
اشكرك جزيلا الشكر احمد سند مهندس هو صانع
محتوى اقتصادي كان معنا في الاستوديو
بحاجه الى جلسه حتى ندرس ميزانيتي
لمتابعتي
المزيد قصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات